Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am
going to explain a French comedy film
called “Jacky in women's Kingdom.”
Spoilers ahead! Watch out and take care!
The movie is set in an imaginary matriarchal
totalitarian country called the Bubunia. In
Bubunia, the roles of men and women are reversed,
up to the point where the male population is
deprived of any civil rights, including work,
education, military service, freedom of marriage,
etc. Men wear headscarves and long veils to cover
every part of their body and dress modestly.
While women are allowed to wear pants and shirts.
The country has been led by the family of ruthless
female Generaless for decades. Moreover, the
significant positions in politics, business,
and the military are all held by women while
men are expected to do all the domestic work and
look pretty for women’s pleasure. In the opening
scene, we are introduced to a handsome young man
named Jacky who is whipped for Generaless's
daughter and the future leader of the state,
the Coloness. The television shows a live
ceremony from the Grand Mushery Palace.
The event is held by the Generaless to announce
something important to the people and also to
execute the male criminals of the month.
Before the ceremony, two royal white horses
are worshipped as per tradition. They
are considered sacred in the country.
Then the honorable ministers of the nation,
who are all women, are introduced. At last,
the Coloness and the Generaless appear in front
of the cheering crowd. The Coloness is the most
eligible bachelor of the town and is liked by all
while her mother and the ruler Generaless is very
strict and is feared by everyone. Jacky does
household work while watching the show on TV.
Just then, his mother returns from work
exhausted. Jacky tends to her needs and
the two watch the show while chatting. His mother
claims that four girls from the town asked for her
permission to marry him at her work. It is clear
that Jacky is popular among the girls of the town
because of his beauty. They hit on the guy
every day, to the point, he feels violated.
Although he can get any girl he likes, Jacky only
has the Coloness in his heart and wishes to marry
her someday. In the show, the criminals are hanged
in front of a cheering crowd. In Bubunia, the only
source of nutrition is a white sticky substance
that is delivered from waterpipe-like sinks called
Paste. The Generaless then gives a speech stating
the importance of the “paste”. She also declares
that she wants to resign from her post and hand
the responsibility over to the Coloness.
But as per tradition, the Coloness needs to
be married before taking over the throne.
She announces that all the men from the country
should compete against each other for a chance
to marry the Coloness and become the “Big Dummy”.
She ends the speech by inviting every man to the
Grand Bubunnery ball for the competition. Jacky
is overly delighted by the announcement. He runs
outside in happiness jumping and dancing like
every other man in the country. One the way,
he sees a group of men praying to a random horse
to make them the big dummy. He joins them and
prays as well. One of the men is Jacky’s cousin
Vergio who claims that the horse talked to him
and said he will be the big dummy. Jacky calls
him out stating that lying is a big blasphemy. As
they talk, some teenage girls nearby call Jacky
hot and argue about who is going to marry him.
Following that, Jacky, Vergio, and his brother
go to a clothing shop to buy veils for the Grand
Bubunnery ball. Vergio’s parents are rich in
contrast to Jacky’s mother. They make fun of
him for not being able to afford a nice vail.
The salesgirl hits on Jacky saying that he is
the most handsome of them all and that she
imagines him on her bed every night.
Jacky, who feels uncomfortable, starts talking to
the shop’s owner but she too asks him to marry her
daughter. Back at home, Jacky writes poetry, which
is uncommon for his gender, while his brother
Julin makes love to a woman in the other room.
Julin is a prostitute whose ambition is to leave
the country one day. He has been told that the
people from other countries are allowed to dance,
sing, and eat varieties of food, in contrast to
their sticky paste. Moreover, he believes that
Jacky’s father had a treasure hidden somewhere
which he will soon find. He asks his brother
to help him with the mission but Jacky claims
he has enough reasons to stay in the country.
The following day, Jacky and his mother go
to buy tickets for the Grand Bubunnery ball
but come across protesters outside the
ticket counter. It turns out that the men
wishing to become the big dummy should pay
forty thousand Bubes which most men cannot
afford because they live in poverty.
Jacky’s uncle and his family come out after
buying the bright red ticket to the ball. They
make fun of his mother for being poor and boast
about how Vergio is going to marry the Coloness.
Jacky returns home and cries himself to bed.
Later, he brings the police to his own house,
accusing his brother Julin of not returning his
money. He believes that their father had left them
a treasure that Julin has been hiding from them.
As the police search through their house,
they find no treasure but get their hands
on a foreign magazine that is forbidden
in the country. To Jacky’s surprise,
Julin is arrested for possession. He apologizes
to his mother saying that it was not his intention
but it is too late now. However, his guilt turns
into happiness when the Sheriffess, gives him a
free ticket to the ball in turn of him reporting
Julin. The very next day, he happily goes to the
clothing store again to get himself clothes for
the ball. When returning, he sees an ambulance
bringing his mother to the hospital. Jacky quickly
rushes to his mother’s side only to find out that
she had slipped and broken her neck. She says
the last goodbye to her son and passes away.
After the incident, Jacky starts to live with his
uncle’s family who hates him and treats him like a
servant. They make him prepare the paste for hours
and spit it out saying it isn’t mashed enough. One
day, he hears them talk about Julin escaping from
the prison and assume he died when his house was
burnt down. Jacky freezes in shock, knowing that
he has no one by his side now. He is at the shop
complaining to a salesgirl about his problems.
The girl, who is also attracted to Jacky,
offers him a ride to the grand ball in turn for
sexual favors. However, while they are at it,
they are caught by Jacky’s uncle. Upon inspection,
they find Jacky’s ticket to the ball and decide to
give it to Vergio’s younger brother. Jacky cries
in vain seeing his only opportunity to a good life
getting away. Then, Vergio and his brother get
ready in beautiful vails to finally go to the
ball. Jacky reluctantly helps them get ready.
One day before the ball, all the contestants in
beautiful while vail arrive at the palace. The
event is televised nationwide. Jacky is at home
crying when he hears someone telling him to run
away. He believes that it is the sacred horse
speaking and manages to run away from his aunt’s
home. After running in the rain for a while,
three women stop him and ask him why he is out.
Taking advantage of the poor guy’s situation,
they assault him sexually. Just then, Julin
appears out of nowhere and kills the women
to save his brother. He claims that he provided
sexual favors to the guards and freed himself
from the prison. He has been living in
the forest and growing plants ever since.
Julin then shows Jacky a turnip farm, proving
that the paste isn’t the only thing humans can
eat and that the generaless has been lying
to everyone. Julin’s plan is to sell the
turnips and get enough money to buy passports and
leave the country. He includes Jacky in his plan
and the two change into “women’s clothes''
and wear wigs to disguise themselves.
Julin also reveals that their father was a rebel
who wanted equal rights for men. They founded a
secret movement for men's rights called Meninism.
But he was hanged for his efforts. The two then
get on a horse and make their way to the palace
to sell the turnips. They meet a higher officer
who happens to know Julin’s secret and asks for a
sexual favor. Jacky is sent outside so he wanders
around the palace and eventually ends up at the
ball. Several men in the same vail are impatiently
waiting for the Coloness’s arrival. Some minutes
later, the Coloness and the generaless arrive at
the ball. Jacky is self speechless by the
Coloness’s beauty. As she scans through the
crowd of men, her eyes land on Jacky, who is still
dressed like a woman. They make eye contact but
Jacky looks away flustered. Then, the men surround
the Coloness trying to prove they are submissive
and hence, eligible to be the big dummy.
Meanwhile, Jacky is approached by his uncle
and his younger son. They mistake him for a girl
and ask him to marry the younger son. Jacky shoos
them away and makes his way to the Coloness. She
seems to be interested in him even though he is
in women's clothing. He introduces himself as
Jacquline and is invited to her private chamber.
There, Jacky and the Coloness talk for a long
time about different things. She tells him that
she wants to be a writer rather than a leader
but her mother won’t let her. She also explains
that the ball is just a satire to earn money
and that she is set to marry a movie star.
She then gives him carrots to eat saying that the
“paste” is only for poor people. As the two talk,
the Coloness starts getting closer to
Jacky initiating sexual advances. But they
are disturbed by the generaless who wants the
Coloness to come back to the ball. Now, the big
dummy is about to be announced when Jacky’s uncle
recognizes him in the crowd and attacks him.
Jacky’s wig is taken off and he announces his love
to the Coloness as a man. But the generaless sends
her guards behind him. A chase ensues in the
palace; Jacky eventually ends up in a secret
room with several pipes. Upon investigation, he
finds out that the paste they have been eating
is recycled human feces mixed with vitamins.
The generaless has been giving speeches about
the paste being a gift to the nation, but in
reality, she is feeding the poor their own feces,
so they won’t eat away all the food
and vegetables. After knowing this,
Jacky presses a button in the control panel that
causes the feces to go to the water pipes without
being filtered. The whole country is now supplied
with disgusting feces mixed with water.
Coloness is on her bed when she hears noises from
under it. She finds Jacky inside and asks him
his true motive. He confesses his love to her and
the two spend the night together. In the morning,
she shows him a crowd of men outside the palace.
Because he revealed the truth about the paste,
the entire country believes Jacky to be a hero.
However, the generaless doesn’t share the view,
so when he and the Coloness are in bed, the
guards arrest him and throw him in jail.
The Generaless comes to visit him in the prison
and offers him a deal: life and marriage to her
daughter in exchange for his cooperation in
preventing rebellion. Jacky accepts the offer
but she tries to cut off his tongue stating that
he has seen too much. But before she can harm him,
the Coloness strangles her to death. Following
that, the new lovers reunite and kiss.
Together, the two open the borders
of Bubunia and establish democracy
in the country. Jacky opens schools for boys
and travels the world. They also introduce
emancipation and restore the country's agriculture
where people are provided with green foods,
not feces. In the last scene, when Coloness
and Jacky are about to officially marry, they
announce that Bubunia wants "no more secrets from
its people" and strip naked in front of the crowd,
revealing that Coloness is actually a man and
that they, in fact, just entered gay marriage.
It turns out that Generaless had no daughters
despite years of trying, so she wanted her last
child to become the state leader despite being
male. The film ends with a woman from the crowd
yelling "Blasphemy!" at the two.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thanks for watching.